how's it gone Bryce is back and welcome
to I am bread as the French call it sure
suis une baguette they updated the game
I don't know if this was here before but
you can play as a cheese
now wait you can play as a cracker
that's racist
I don't appreciate that the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm a connect you but uh I'm not
connected up that's these type of bread
in Swedish whoo
connect your bra click a prop but can't
get block oh no I cracked I cracked like
a Swedish kicker bruh you like like a
bra bra
oh man I'm sick I'm the best connect a
Brian the bra bra yeah must find cheese
actually cheese is not that good on
these I would put some maybe Jam [ __ ] I
don't I'm genuinely trying here so don't
give me where looks alright being a
cracker it's not that easy
alright where's the cheese it's over
there okay we can do this Bruce I have
100% faith in that we have ah ah
the controls are soulful ah calm down
mate so any way to control this cracker
bread there we go
oh yeah no go up [ __ ] sake mate what
are you doing flip it flip it you need
it you need a tactic here bro there you
are yeah
being a connect abre isn't that hard ah
I think I just broke my spine it's not
fair
this game is not fair this game is not
you're being [ __ ] Hitler right now a
game well [ __ ] you then I have no
integrity what are you gonna do game
judge me
alright [ __ ] you you don't know me go
ah [ __ ] you and your and this camera
angles aren't [ __ ] ah ah ah we did it
no yeah ah nah but the [ __ ] where's the
cheese are you kidding me where's the
chase I'm a cracker there's the [ __ ]
cheese my god I've been so blind all
this life so how do I go down there
without dying horrible death
don't do it cracker
a cracker humping a skateboard it's 2015
all right ah what is this what is this I
don't ask for this no where are you
taking me what the what I'm a cracker
kickflip er ah you correct me you
[ __ ]
ah so strong please please please please
up Wow damn how the [ __ ] it in market
Ibuka am I gonna go up there what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you doing what
it's my life how all right climbing
skills engage
grab something grab something for the
love god oh alright alright alright let
go ah yes jeez where's the cheese
there's no no no no no there has to be
cheese there has to be cheese inside
this box no no wait hey it can't be true
there must be cheese inside this
[ __ ] ah see you you [ __ ]
cheesy mother [ __ ]
I don't wanna close my eyes I don't
wanna fall asleep cuz I need the cheese
and I don't wanna miss the slaves open
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] or I will cut
a [ __ ] alright what if we push it off
the edge
find all the cheese or maybe those
molded oh oh oh my god
I've been miss I just murdered my friend
tonight sorry Bernie
though those those discussing parts are
the cheese I get it now
cheesy does it shut up shut your [ __ ]
mouth
bring it bring your a-game yes yes if we
get the cheese where's my cheese huh
where's my cheese that I got it fell on
did you have to however all right I just
suck it up is that it is it on top yeah
got the cheese we got one cheese how
long was that 20 minutes no big deal all
right
more cheese more cheese Rock damn that
was pretty epic Oh
alright go oh please please leave huh
yeah wait I wasn't supposed to do the
chair hi Ken I'm Ken I can't [ __ ]
beat I can't I can't I can't you happy
for its level I can't I can't even [ __ ]
you become toast
alright now I'll bread now I'm a brain
in where where am i living room why am I
here you know I'm just gonna go straight
to
why what's wrong with carpets like you
never ate your toast if we landed on a
carpet all right so well how the [ __ ]
are we supposed to do this then relying
on the box got it nicely done POS thanks
pills
don't talk to yourself [ __ ] yes yes
yes it's all about skills on the hills
there we go yes yes ah is that Taylor
Swift Taylor you look so good today oh
my god Taylor whoa MLG MLG replay that
MLG replay that hi how's everyone doing
that's great I don't give a [ __ ] all
right
excuse me excuse me am I supposed to
take the skateboard I don't trust this
oh god oh god oh god what the [ __ ] did I
do with my life oh ah ah skateboard
skateboard you traitor you traitor it
you traitorous swine yes yes baby yes
baby sexist Texas dropped me and you do
the Panda [ __ ] that only Pitt but you
piece of [ __ ] I've come too far Linkin
Park was here right now they'd be
singing some cheesy [ __ ] song yes Wow
take our lives for granted but we forget
how [ __ ] hard it is for other people
like if you're a braid for example look
at all the [ __ ] you have to go through I
need to go to the heater
right like that would that's the only
way I can imagine us getting toasted
gravity ha oh no no no no no how am I
supposed to know what the red will duh
oh yes
that's how we do it in Sweden every day
every day girl you [ __ ] me oh wow
did you see her first weirder first
murder right yeah and all my friends
over in the polar bears oh god yes now
what do we need to slink in that hole or
like how do you slink into holes I like
it how how how how does one [ __ ] go
in apparently you're supposed to break
the television and that ptosis you
that's is my idea that I randomly got in
my head did not look it up or anything
stupid like that oh god I have to go all
the way glass what are you doing
oh cool it's it's really happening all
right cool I'm a bread for life girl
come on are you losing your [ __ ] tits
for me there we go this is how we
usually climb in Sweden this is not this
is not one of those things where a Wi-Fi
fail I'll just do it again no this is
either we do this now or it's never ever
ever happening oh oh how do i how do we
now we just have one more step to do one
more little step yeah that's right I'm
getting toasted baby I'm getting toasted
Oh yi I like it a little extra burn
don't even worry about it
wow thank you for watching this video
where I reach my shita
where I lose my [ __ ] hope you enjoyed if
you want more hit that like button and
I'll [ __ ] do more thang watching as
always stay awesome bros and slapping in
heart lay on his buttom yeah yeah yeah